[Música]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy herminia Fernández la población de
origina en saporilla está llamada a ser
estratégica en la contraofensiva que
planean lanzar la fuerza sucranianas
para recuperar territorios ocupados
ubicada menos de cinco kilómetros del
frente orillita está en el camino a las
ciudades melitopol y verdians que buscan
ser recuperadas por el gobierno de kiev
así vive la población que permanece en
la ciudad en estos momentos de
expectativa en los que todo se preguntan
cuándo comenzará la contraofensiva el
reporte es de Catalina Gómez Ángel
no hay un rincón de orihib que haya
quedado a salvo de los ataques de las
fuerzas rusas esto incluye la sede del
gobierno local donde sigue operando un
centro de distribución de ayuda
humanitaria
los pocos pobladores que no se han
marchado de la ciudad Se acercan a
recoger provisiones necesarias para
sobrevivir
Constantino asegura que han terminado
por acostumbrarse a esta nueva situación
ellos destruyen y nosotros reconstruimos
esto sucede todo el tiempo hay gente que
ha tenido la casa destruida cinco veces
muchas veces las tenemos que cubrir con
los plásticos de las carpas humanitarias
porque es imposible arreglarlas por
completo desde el comienzo de la
invasión la línea de frente quedó a
menos de cuatro kilómetros de origen
entonces las fuerzas rusas avanzaron
hasta tomar el control de la mitad de la
provincia de saporilla
es uno de los soldados responsables de
defender el espacio aéreo en la región
su audacia para derribar aviones 6 hasta
el momento que ha valido el título de
héroe de Ucrania a pesar de tener solo
19 años
trabajaríamos mejor con armas adecuadas
Por ejemplo yo uso un sistema de defensa
portátil de defensa aérea de fabricación
soviético que eran comunes en la década
de los 70 y 80 Así que hay desventajas
porque no son precisos
los ataques con artillería han
disminuido pero los rusos ahora azotan
la ciudad con bombas más potentes este
es el caso de este colegio destruido A
mediados de abril muchos creen que esta
es una respuesta anticipada de Rusia a
la contraofensiva que planea Ucrania en
las próximas semanas para retomar
territorios ocupados
todo puede pasar en cualquier momento
ayer Fue increíble todo de repente
estaba bajo fuego detrás de ese edificio
hubo una gran columna
trabaja en el centro de invencibilidad
un refugio donde se da apoyo a la
población
la gran esperanza de todos está puesta
en la contraofensiva ucraniana que
esperan que les traiga nuevamente la
calma Aunque por el momento ni ella ni
el resto de la población sabe cuándo
comenzará
el puerto de amberes en el norte de
bélica es uno de los mayores
embarcaderos de Europa ahora es
considerada la entrada principal de
droga proveniente de América Latina
sobre todo de Colombia y Ecuador en 2022
incautaron más de 100 toneladas de
cocaína un récord que se supera año tras
año y que preocupan las autoridades
belgas nuestra corresponsal en Bélgica
Esther Herrera nos cuenta más
es un nuevo día en el puerto de amberes
uno de los funcionarios que pide no ser
identificado analiza el último
cargamento que acaba de llegar
debe verificar que no hay trazos de
droga este embarcadero belga es
considerado la puerta principal de
entrada de cocaína Europa solo en 2022
se incautaron 110 toneladas
un contenedor puede ser seleccionado por
sospechas de narcotráfico por ello
siempre abrimos este tipo de cargamentos
y buscamos entre todos los paquetes o
bien entre aquellos que el escáner haya
identificado como sospechosos
con 240 millones de toneladas de
mercancías al año y con 160 kilómetros
cuadrados de extensión el puerto de
amberes es uno de los que maneja mayor
volumen de tráfico en Europa fogón
portavoz de aduanas advierte que los
cargamentos provenientes de América
Latina sobre todo los que contienen
fruta son los que más preocupan
queremos aumentar el control de
contenedores que provienen de América
Latina
por eso Hay nuevas inversiones que
anunció el gobierno belga de 70 millones
de euros y con el compromiso de
contratar a 118 aduaneros
la lucha por combatir el contrabando de
estupefacientes se ha convertido en
motivo de preocupación la comisaria
europea interior el vallohansson
recientemente firmó un acuerdo de
cooperación entre Bélgica y Ecuador para
controlar Los buques que salen a Europa
el tráfico de cocaína en la Unión
Europea está aumentando y se estima que
tiene un beneficio de 10 mil millones de
euros este dinero va directamente a las
organizaciones criminales
al gobierno de Bélgica le preocupa que
el país se convierta en un narco estado
por ello ya ha señalado que no
escatimará recursos para dejar el puerto
de amberes libre del narcotráfico
el guaraní no solo es uno de las monedas
más antiguas de América Latina también
es una de las más estables a pesar de la
inflación récord que ha vivido Paraguay
los últimos dos años causada por la
pandemia y por el alza del precio del
combustible la moneda paraguaya resiste
mejor que en los países vecinos nuestros
corresponsales se reconstruyeron la
historia del guaraní creada en 1943
chiva cocido los precios asustan los
guaraníes se cuentan por millares pero
cuando se hace el cambio al Dólar no es
para tanto la mayoría de los productos
en este mercado viene de Argentina
la comparación de o sea el cambio con el
peso está buenísimo nuestro guaraní es
la moneda más estable de Sudamérica
como vos Y pase ha pasado muchas cosas
en el Paraguay pero por lo menos su
moneda sigue todavía estable
el museo de numismática en la sede del
Banco Central de Paraguay reconstruye la
historia de esta moneda que en Octubre
cumple 80 años
nuestra historia es muy inestable con
muchas guerras internas y dos guerras
internacionales muy grandes que fueron
la de la Triple Alianza que fue una
pelea contra Argentina Brasil y este
Uruguay este conflicto aniquiló la mitad
de la población y mató al 90% de los
varones en edad militar paradójicamente
la inestabilidad política dio origen a
la moneda más estable de Sudamérica a
día de hoy no se sabe por qué decidieron
bautizarla con el nombre del pueblo
indígena lo que cuenta la gente es que
el decreto tenía que salir a la mañana y
a medianoche no sabían todavía Qué
nombre ponerle entonces ahí alguien se
le ocurrió y salió el nombre guaraní que
es en este momento la moneda cuya
denominación es la más antigua después
del peso colombiano verdad en América
Latina para facilitar
las transacciones monetarias en 2009
surgió un proyecto para quitar terceros
al guaraní que da por ver si el nuevo
gobierno retomará un proyecto que
suscita dudas por miedo que genere aún
más inflación
la gastronomía colombiana continúa
posicionándose a nivel internacional
esta vez de la mano del chef Juan Camilo
Quintero un jovengono que hace unos años
abandonó los estudios de ingeniería para
formarse como chef en Italia esta
decisión le ha traído grandes
satisfacciones entre ellas ser premiado
por la guía michelín la guía de
restaurantes más importante del mundo
también ha recibido el reconocimiento
como el mejor chef joven en el festival
de gastronomía de Roma nuestra
corresponsal Natalia Mendoza lo visitó
en su restaurante en la región de
Toscana
en este restaurante de cocina gourmet en
Toscana Juan Camilo Quintero dirige una
brigada de 18 personas
este chef colombiano de 33 años es una
de las revelaciones del selecto mundo de
la alta cocina en Italia combinando
técnicas Sabores y siguiendo un objetivo
contar aquí en Italia en Europa la lo
maravilloso y lo lindo que es Colombia
su cultura sus productos Entonces
siempre vas a notar una influencia
exótica la fruta exótica como la hierbas
el cilantro y demás que te permite
viajar viajar con el paladar a través de
recetas como esta a base de hoja de
plátano la hoja de plátano va a sacarle
el aroma de la hoja que luego
envolviendo el producto va a
aromatizarse desde su llegada a Italia
Hace 13 años la trayectoria de Juan
Camilo ha sido fulgurante en el 2020 su
restaurante recibió una estrella
michelín la recompensa más del mundo
gastronómico a la cual se suma una
estrella Michelin verde que premia los
esfuerzos en favor de la sostenibilidad
lo ecológico y lo social gracias a
proyectos como este huerto orgánico a
pocos pasos de su restaurante en el cual
trabajan personas con discapacidad nos
da la posibilidad de tener hierbas y
vegetales frescos en primavera salen las
arvejas las habas los hinojos el
restaurante como actividad económica es
depredadora como muchas otras por la
lógicas de la distribución no del
comprar volúmenes de comida producir es
hora de que los cocineros y el
consumidor también se interrogue si lo
que estamos poniendo en los platos en
los menús de los restaurantes es
correcto o no en su cocina Juana aboga
por el mínimo desperdicio de
ingredientes cada plato es un trabajo
minucioso fruto del esfuerzo y la
dedicación de Este joven talento
decidido a seguir conquistando los
paladares más exigentes del viejo
continente
hasta que corresponsales de la semana
hoy desde la Feria Internacional del
Libro desde Bogotá sigue con más
información en Francia 24 y Francia
24.com